I was just listening to what you were
saying and to me what's fascinating is
that um the combination of the Utley
emotional and the data so which world do
you think will start winning before
everyone gets wise will it be the
emotional side will it be the data side
before we get to the pie but it depends
on the judge right like it's a human a
flute a flawed human being because we're
all flawed a flawed a human being will
make that decision so in some
organization it's gonna be the creative
because the decision maker likes
creative I mean listen we lose business
in my agency because we're asking people
to story-tell twenty-four hours a day
it's hard news alert if you're still
confused marketing got [ __ ] hard
right and so we have a lot of people
who'd rather shoot a television
commercial because here's what you do if
you're spending a lot of money on TV
right you spend lots of time on it save
tons of time to not mess it up right
number two you get to go on the shoot a
lot of times so you what sounds more
interesting putts around with something
for six months and then go to New
Zealand for two weeks and be on the
shoot and really not have to do anything
and then God forbid if you get lucky you
get to go to the South of France or
catch a reward or what I pitched them
which is you can't sleep ever again the
customer matters and you need to put out
content every day and if you put up the
wrong piece of confident could be bad I
mean it's like not even close right so
that decision is there but if somebody's
a young progressive marketer and they're
thinking about their future and the
legacy and they know this is right they
realized wait a minute let me ride this
wave because this is gonna help me long
term so the real answer is if the CEO of
a entrepreneurial venture is a
data-driven gal she's gonna go with the
data that's who's gonna win if the CEO
is a guy who used to be the former
creative director at r/ga
he's gonna go with the creative it's the
judge is the answer to that question you
keep mentioning storytelling I'm very
passionate about that as well but we're
here to learn from the experts we love
best practice yes was there a
storytelling moment within your
organization that you went to bed at her
at home that night and thought that was
perfect no
was there anything that came close to
perfect you know it's it's not perfect
you know to me it was funny I realized
something I'm a big boxing fan hence the
title my new book Jab Jab Jab right hook
and obviously there was a humongous
fight this Saturday and like you know
I'm watching this guy Floyd Mayweather
and he's supposed to maybe be finished
eventually one day it might happen but
it still doesn't and I'm watching the
way he fights and I understand boxing
extremely well and I'm like somewhere on
the seventh round I'm like ah that's how
I'm um that's how I am as a business man
I'm a counter puncher see nothing can be
perfect for me because I never set out
to do anything I set up for one goal
professionally I have one goal to buy
the New York Jets right and so that's my
goal right there's no in-between right
every decision I make I'm being serious
every decision I make that I think about
that and so what I'm doing my whole life
is I'm counterpunching I'm reacting to
what the consumers doing and I'm giving
them value in return and so for me I've
never thought of campaigns right there's
never that's never been in my mind as a
maverick even the campaign work we now
do comes from insights from the micro
content we produce that one GE six
second science which is a huge win for
us right now in the advertising world it
came from one vine video that over-index
said data wise made us pay attention
then made us to more creative it
over-index a data wise we felt confident
that there was something there and we
pictured a bigger campaign that's that's
counterpunching for business instead of
sitting in a room you know and being
creative and be like I got it
unicorns right like that you know and so
you know the reason I say never perfect
because for me it's always it's kind of
like hedging like if you're responding
and you're if you actually give a crap
about the end consumer you have the
ability to with the data we have in
place now actually listen to them if you
actually then want to deliver on what
they want whatever that may be you're
gonna win if you can find a way to
actually extract some sort of profit
from that you're gonna win and so that's
why I spend my time on how can I do
things for other people you know Jab Jab
Jab right hook give give give ask yeah
now that's the question that's coming up
now is about the influencers we've heard
a lot today about the power of the
influences
you called the influences and when do
you finally close the deal are we
talking about influencer marketing to an
extent yes so this is an interesting
conversation I struggle with influencer
marketing because I believe that the
consumers [ __ ] radar is much much
better than it was a decade ago and that
you know when you think about extracting
value from somebody else to endorse your
product that's great
and it's fine and it can be a moment but
you're not building equity for yourself
you're borrowing equity so I'm not a big
fan of it in general though I did start
a vine agency to rep vine celebrities
because I do feel in video form and like
branded content you can do a little bit
more for example I would I've never ever
you know as somebody who had a lot of
Twitter followers I've never tweeted a
tweet for promotion purposes I've never
done any business on Instagram or
Pinterest with the influences on those
platforms for brands because I think
there's there's a lack of authenticity
that I think the consumer understands I
mean listen I have never seen a tweet
from a major celebrity that I've known
has done some sort of branded conflict
wheats before and not think cynical that
they're just pitching that product which
then gives you know emotional equity
that product if not it may damage your
equity on the product here's another one
let's talk about EQ for a quick second
Darrelle Revis you know that is he's a
jerk he he left my New York Jets to the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers right in May and
June when it was obviously they were
gonna trade him I was on my phone
constantly I was looking at it every
five minutes every moment I had to see
if they traded him right and I'd go to
espn.com during that period I probably
went to espn.com and at two weeks when
it was hot
I'd probably went there four to five
hundred times just refreshing it right
you know just to see if I could see it
during that time Samsung was running
they pop up ad right so the data will
show you that during this two-week
period user four nine four seven four
three four seven that's me right saw
four hundred impressions and have nine
click throughs my thumbs a little fatter
than I'd like
so actually hit the ad instead of the X
right back home at the agency at Samsung
that's a great click
ratio and some nice impressions and
their high-five meanwhile in real life I
texted my wife on the 20th day of this
and said we are never buying a Samsung
product again ever more importantly I've
tweeted to my million fans
I am never buying a Samsung product [ __ ]
Samsung I'm telling you [ __ ] Samsung and
so the data shows success within the
context but the emotion that I had for
an ad that is so intrusive it's one
thing for a banner or pre-roll or things
of that nature but in mobile where the
whole screen gets taken over and I can't
get to I want and three seconds actually
now actually matters to all of us right
time is the commodity we value it's in
my way and now I hate that brand I don't
like it though the data back home looks
pretty awesome please welcome the CEO of
Samsung I'm already kidding so last
question cuz yes it's almost out yes
some of what you're telling us I have to
be honest it's conflicting with some of
the wise words from our panel well they
want wise so well there has to be a
middle ground so on the Samsung example
one of the points from the panel was
keep swinging even if you miss what is
your position on that I'm guessing
that's not the way to do it so I don't
know the full context and listen every
there's a million ways to skin a cat and
I'll be very honest on the first to
admit I'm running a marathon in a
sprinters world so what I sell and what
I believe and what I drink and the dog
food that I eat is not for everybody if
you want results in a quarter you've got
to mix other things but if you give a
[ __ ] at all about certain things like I
don't know your legacy or or long-term
value or the health of the business you
actually work for this stuff I'm
preaching it needs to be very seriously
considered last question is a yes or no
did you send the champagne to the dad
did I saw the champagne to the debt yes
I did
ladies and gentlemen Gary Vaynerchuk
thank you very much
no thank you
thank you sir